so okay uh first is process
will republicans be able to confirm a
justice to replace ruth bader ginsburg
before the election on november 3rd
before the january 20th inauguration
time
wise days which is what we have roughly
remaining between now and the november
third election
that's very fast typically it takes
about 70 days
from nomination to confirmation for a
supreme court justice so
it would be very tough to do it in the
45 days before the election
but it could happen donald trump
reportedly going to nominate a
replacement for ruth bader ginsburg
this week the bigger question to me
is the lame duck period eve it i don't
know that they need to necessarily
do it before the election because i
believe that even if joe biden
were to win they will have the time and
potentially
the ability potentially the power
potentially the support
to install a replacement for ruth bader
ginsburg
during the interim period the lame duck
period between november
3rd 4th and january 20th now do they
have the votes you need 51 votes
to confirm a supreme court justice or
you need 50 votes
plus the tie-breaking vote from the vice
president which they would have
in mike pence for sure republicans have
a political situation to contend with
because republicans are defending
25 of the 38 senate seats that are on
the ballot
many of their more vulnerable members
have been eager to get back home get out
of uh
dc expected to to be around mid-october
i forget the exact
date and campaign and that would
shorten the pre-election period it's not
really 45 days it's more like 30 or 35
days
because 30 really maybe even 25
because they are planning to end this
session in mid-october now some of those
senators might realize
not only that they need to get back and
campaign
because their seats are at risk but that
pushing forward on this before the
election could actually be bad for their
re-election the balance right now
in the senate is 53 republicans and 47
democrats that's 45 democrats plus two
independents angus king and bernie
sanders who caucus with democrats so
what they need those of us what we need
who oppose uh donald trump getting to
replace rbg
is we need four republican senators to
say no
now very early there was the suspicion
or there were rumors that mitt romney
wasn't going to do this before the
inauguration that was
almost immediately refuted by campaign
staff now
maybe romney wouldn't do it we don't
know yet
the early claims that were made were
merely rumors we then heard from alaska
republican senator
lisa murkowski who put out a very
carefully worded statement saying that
quote i did not support taking up a
nomination
eight months before the 2016 election to
fill the vacancy created
by the passing of justice scalia we are
now
even closer to the 2020 election less
than two months out
and i believe the same standard must
apply so
certainly lisa murkowski is a no before
the election
but there is nothing here and this is
why you have to look at the wording
there's nothing here that says if trump
loses
she may still go forward with a vote to
confirm
during what would be a lame duck period
for donald trump
that's really the question mark
otherwise we really aren't sure
we can speculate susan collins okay
maybe she wouldn't go for it before the
election but what about during the lame
duck
period potential lame duck period corey
gardner in colorado
he might realize this could be very bad
for his re-election
but maybe during the lame duck period we
don't know maybe martha mcsally who's
down
to mark kelly in arizona
uh we just don't know now
we have to look at the hypocrisy and the
reason i'm kind of hesitating is
they don't care they don't care but yes
they are hypocrites
look at some of these quotes from 2016
and 2018
senator ted cruz in 2016 it has been 80
years
since the supreme court vacancy was
nominated and confirmed
in an election year there is a long
tradition
that you don't do this in an election
year hypocrite
lindsey graham in 2018 if an opening
comes in the last year of president
trump's term
and the primary process has started will
wait to the next election
marco rubio i don't think we should be
moving on a nominee
in the last year of this president's
term
i would say that if it was a republican
president well we're waiting marco
tom tillis from north carolina
republican
the campaign is already underway it is
essential to the institution of the
senate
and to the very health of our republic
to not launch our nation
into a partisan divisive confirmation
battle
during the very same time the american
people
are casting their ballots to elect our
next
president now i could go on and on with
more and more of these but ultimately
trumpists have not punished republicans
for heinous
hypocrisy and i have no reason to
believe that they will
this time maybe some individual races
could be affected
but let's circle back around is there
anything positive here because it seems
like this is a disaster for america
giving trump the opportunity to ruin
things not just for four years
not merely for eight years but for
decades the one thing that is very clear
to me
is that this has the possibility to
hugely energize democratic voters
including left-leaning centrists
anti-trump moderates and even many of
the never biden left-wingers
since friday night at 8 pm eastern which
is when the world learned of the
passing of ruth bader ginsburg small
dollar donations have exploded
to democrats 100 million dollars
were donated in the 40 or so hours
following the death
of ruth bader ginsburg people are
reacting
people are donating to biden people are
donating to democrats nationally and
i do believe this will increase voter
turnout
including early voting which we are
already seeing
what can we control here okay we can't
make republicans be consistent
we can't make republicans stop being
hypocrites we can't make
republicans good moral people we can't
control trump
but we can vote and we can lobby and we
can donate and we can phone bank and we
can call our senators let's focus on
what we can do
let me know on twitter what do you
expect to see
with this open seat i'm on twitter at
deepakman
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the
important core ideas and information
from that book
it's perfect if you don't have enough
time to do all the reading you want to
do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25 percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video